la copia della moda è un argomento
complesso che si esprime sin dall'albore
degli Studi di questa disciplina è
importante fare una differenziazione tra
ciò che si intende per copia per plagio
e per ispirazione la copia come moto di
conoscenza e anche implicito al mondo
della moda nella moda industriale noi
realizziamo dei campionari che poi
vengono replicati quindi
è
un moto anche di produzione industriale
rispetto al segmento è fondamentale
pensare che dietro proprio
le teorie più classiche della moda ossia
La teoria della
trickle down Theory ossia
la diffusione dalle classi più alte alle
classi più basse quindi una visione alla
moda Canonica
supportata da autori come Wembley
bourdier
osimmel
la copia cioè l'emulazione di attitudini
o capi ed oggetti sono proprio alla base
di quello che poi è il fenomeno
Questa
classifica è stata poi
rivista in delle
in delle teorie A partire dagli anni 50
definite Bubble Up per esempio da tempo
lemus dove viene scardinata questo
pensiero e si Lascia spazio anche
all'idea che la moda potesse partire dal
basso quindi attraverso anche l'apertura
di questo mondo alle subculture quindi
la copia fa parte
del processo anche di creatività è
qualcosa che è stata sdoganata dalle
arti maggiori a partire da
artiste come stutevant A partire dagli
anni sessanta che copiava esattamente le
opere di Warhol come atto creativo e da
tutte le avanguardie
la moda dell'antropocene della modernità
Si apre anche con creativi come decks
Alia che nella sfilata del
2015 apre la
apre il suo Brand all'epoca vetaman con
una maglietta di DHL indossata da gosha
rubish innski che è un altro importante
designer di gli ultimi vent'anni che ha
legato il suo nome soprattutto allo
streetwear Quindi con quell'atto si
trasla il concerto di copia ossia noi
possiamo potevamo vedere una t-shirt che
era venduta se ero e 50 stock da video
sul sito della DHL rivenduta poi
all'epoca il prezzo era 245 euro da un
Brand di tendenza la forza visiva e di
concetto di donna poi lo ha portato ad
essere il Crati director di Balenciaga e
in tutto questo percorso ha continuato a
lavorare come altri su questo tipo di
poetica quindi
la copia È comunque un linguaggio che
può essere usato nella progettazione
dell'originalità
nell'ambito della del creativo
persone che mi hanno anche preceduto
raccontano Insomma della forza che
questa
che questo moto dell'animo umano della
creatività può avere nella progettazione
è importante
pensare che
all'interno proprio della progettazione
di moda noi
parliamo degli strumenti come la
moodboard o la conoscenza degli archivi
ho dei capi di studio che ci spingono ad
approfondire degli stili che ci spingono
a riconoscere in degli oggetti primigeni
un un
centro di studio che che poi non
dovrebbe essere copiato ma ma che ci
stimola a un nuovo un nuovo linguaggio
dei nuovi significati
l'aspetto di creatività legato a i moti
della moda quindi quel tutto ciò che è
emulazione che con la differenziazione
rappresenta il
uno dei moti più classici appunto del
fenomeno è differente da ciò che noi
discorriamo come plagio il plagio è
qualcosa che
rientra nell'ambito giuridico che ha
avuto nell'ambito del fashion design uno
sviluppo A partire dagli anni 70 Ossia
da dalla diffusione di un capitalismo
della conoscenza quindi dove anche i
Brand di moda hanno iniziato ad essere
delle
delle realtà economiche importanti molto
spesso proprio per la realtà effimera
per la moda per i processi di linguaggio
che ho prima citato e labile e complesso
definire che cosa sia un plagio questo è
anche derivato dalle differenti
legislazioni esempio la
legislazione americana è molto specifica
nel tutelare per l'autonomia creativa
l'opera d'arte Ma l'oggetto di moda
viene
identificato come oggetto funzionale
quindi in in questo caso sono molto e
meno le protezioni che avvengono su esso
è differente il caso in Italia ma
bisogna molto spesso ragionare caso per
caso
Brand di qualità differenti quindi molto
più legati alla creatività
all'artigianalità possono usare la copia
come diffusione è interessante pensare
che in uno dei degli dei libri degli
ultimi anni che design vaiarsidens di
Alexandra midal ridata proprio la
nascita del design Al di là del
principio di
dell'arsene Craft di Morris o
dell'esperienza dei Bauhaus Alla
diffusione delle competenze domestiche
quindi anche delle abilità di
riproduzione di un certo tipo di gusto
di moda
nell'Ottocento nelle riviste americane
è bello questo aspetto di
in considerazione della datazione anche
di nascita di alcuni sistemi perché ci
porta anche alla moda più contemporanea
alla nascita di un microcosmo di piccoli
Brand o di creativi diy ossia di with
Yourself che nella creazione di
archetipi che poi possono anche essere
di prodotti a casa creano anche un
artigianalità diffusa ripensano il
sistema della moda Quindi bisogna
proprio
nell'ottica del design comprendere bene
quando parlare di copia quando la copia
serve anche alla diffusione di un
messaggio e un sistema sociale di sapere
anche legata alla creazione degli
oggetti e quando invece come in alcuni
casi in maniera aggressiva alcune realtà
sia appropiano di oggetti pensati da
altre strutture e
riproducono cercando di andare
di
approfittare dell'originalità dello
studio e
che vi è dietro un oggetto una
progettazione di moda
appunto in questo periodo che ho citato
nascere
negli ultimi 15 anni quindi di una
postmodernismo
in maniera orizzontale diffuso in tutto
il sistema moda ci sono proprio dei casi
dove questa attitudine a questa
citando Valentina tanni Meme estetica
diventa uno strumento di comunicazione
esempio diesel nel 2018 aperto un pop up
che si chiamava Days dove vendeva
proprio degli oggetti
contraffatti in realtà prodotti dal
Brand stesso quindi
fondamentale una riflessione su Che
cos'è la copia e che cos'è il plagio ma
anche che cos'è un Brand oggi nel
sistema moda perché la moda non nasce
soltanto per i Brand nasce anche per la
creazione di prodotti legati
all'abbigliamento e una creatività
condivisa siamo passati da una creazione
di valore di sistema e di linguaggio che
quella spiegata in un testo molto noto
di kawamura che è una studiosa americana
dove si
le riconosceva come la l'esaltazione
della figura anche del creativo e dello
stilista della moda serve a creare un
significato questo significato poi viene
trasportato negli oggetti e anche poi
nella copia di questi oggetti Io credo
che
le persone l'utente finale sappia in
qualche modo comunque
distinguere ed oggi in un sistema
possibilità di sostenibilità la nostra
domanda non è deve essere soltanto se
l'oggetto è più o meno contraffatto o se
delle grandi realtà industriali in
maniera aggressiva
sia proprio di idee di altri ma anche
queste realtà industriali come producono
questi oggetti che sono contraffatti
Quali sono le tutele sull'ambiente sul
lavoro e forse proprio nella nel futuro
della progettazione di moda bisogna
ripensare i significati
negli ultimi 40 anni di studio della
moda è stato importante
identificare gli attori e le reti di
significato oggi ci sono degli autori
tra cui callon o
[Musica]
Bruno La Tour che hanno esteso il
sistema di significato e gli attori non
sotto agli attori umani ma anche
imprenditori in umani cioè nel momento
in cui noi consideriamo un oggetto
dobbiamo
pensare anche a come questo oggetto è
stato creato Quali sono gli attori che
concorrono alla creazione di questo
oggetto Come vivrà nella storicità della
sua del suo corso di esistenza e quindi
potremmo anche considerare l'acqua
elemento naturale come uno degli oggetti
in umani di degli attori in umani di
significato esempio potremmo riprodurre
oggetti di abbigliamento similari ma
prodotti preservando per esempio l'acqua
o il riciclo o di essa Quindi se da un
certo punto di vista l'apparenza
dell'oggetto potrà essere similare
per come è fatto per come è costruito
quindi poi anche il suo significato
cambierà come noi percepiremo
quell'oggetto e ed è per questo che
quando noi parliamo di plagio dobbiamo
estendere forse anche l'aggressività di
questa parola non soltanto a la
espropriazione della dell'identità
creativa dello studio che è stato a
volte anche copia Ma poi che è diventato
forze espressiva che riconoscibile a mio
avviso da tutti ma soprattutto ha delle
entità entità aziendali che depauperano
non soltanto la creatività degli autori
ma dei Papa erano le culture oppure li
anche proprio l'ambiente è fondamentale
pensare che negli ultimi anni
attraverso anche i moti del post
coloniale la moda ha cominciato a
prendere coscienza di Cosa significa
anche
ispirarsi
come separazione dal copiare oppure
Ripeto questo termine depauperare altre
culture da Oggetti simbolici
si pone molta più attenzione
in maniera globale a che cosa significa
Qual è il significato della copia anche
Quali sono i limiti di Essa infatti
Molto della comunicazione contemporanea
a partire da blog come Diet Prada a
stimolato tutti coloro che concorrono
come attori all'interno del sistema moda
a ripensare le azioni anche di
creatività che noi facciamo a partire da
ciò che mettiamo nei nostri moodboard
alla necessità di citare o le
collaborazioni che noi facciamo di dare
valore anche
alle storie degli oggetti degli archivi
qui o di coloro che hanno un sapere
artigiano che qui che quindi deve essere
preservato a far parte proprio della
creazione di valore e conoscenza degli
oggetti
è importante pensare che in un ottica
globale
molto spesso questa sovrappopolazione di
immagini crei sicuramente una una
piramide di valori quindi ci sono dei
Brand maggiori che hanno potenza
Maggiore anche di comunicazione che
vengono copiate da entità che hanno
proprio alla base del loro concetto
industriale la riproduzione
in maniera più economica e ripeto l'idea
di economico molto spesso con catene di
produzione non tutelate
il gli oggetti ma anche importante
pensare che ci sono una miriade di
compagni di designer quindi di realtà
indipendenti che vedono espropriate le
proprie
idee E quindi poi
notano come aziende industriali
strutturate hanno guadagni maggiori
della propria idea di produzione Quindi
anche legata allo Small business e il
tema della copia Quindi è la moda è
complesso perché se da un lato fa parte
proprio della catena di significati
quindi dei linguaggi di essa dall'altro
invece con Lima con un aspetto della del
dell'attuale sistema moda industriale
quindi un sistema che non è soltanto un
sistema legato ai significati creativi
Ma che è necessariamente
deve dialogare con le giurisdizioni
locali e anche con dei sistemi economici
molto complessi Grazie
[Applauso]